how's it going everybody maximum Iggy
here with Oliver from Romano and today
we're checking out swords and soldiers
to Oliver thank you for sitting down on
the couch with me and for feeding me
delicious cookies earlier no problem so
tell me about swords and soldiers to
obviously sequel to the previous game
what was sort of your guys's goal
setting out to make this sequel well
basically we want to make a way better
swords and soldiers like we made sort of
soldiers 15 years ago and we've grown as
company we've made Awesomenauts and yeah
we learned so much in the meantime that
looking back at Sur the soldiers one we
we always thought well that can be a way
better game and that's basically what
sure you have plenty of ideas like
cooking during the devel- swords and
soldiers one that you just couldn't
quite work in you've always wanted to go
back to that's always problem with game
design once you get to the end of
development you have to kind of start
wrapping things up and you stop putting
in new ideas but you still get those
ideas so and also as ideas are put in
for souls to it can you tell me some of
the new ideas some of the new features
that are making it into the sequel well
and in part one we had super spells for
each faction yet a super spell and in
solar so let's do we have super units as
well and they get all kinds of different
tricks that you can use yeah I think
we're gonna see one of those super units
here in just a little bit but I guess we
should set up why we're fighting a tiny
goblin on what looks like a golf course
yeah this this level is the campaign
will be about red beard and is
adventurous and in this level red beard
pays visit to his grandpa who i believe
is retired he's enjoying a bit of golf
exactly has a little girl for a long
time but it's besieged by demons so
that's been a problem frame so we're
Vikings big golfers did you guys do a
lot of like historical background
research into this yeah black ninety
percent of other gentleman's time was
spent on research it's good that's good
that's good to know yeah yeah so it's
very important that's like that's like
games on 101 yeah you got it you got to
make sure your facts are straight when
you're dealing with the get the epic
battle of Vikings demons
yeah yeah you have to know that this
took place like in 1943 ah so let's talk
let's talk that portal there in the sand
trap because I believe that is a new
addition for sorting say yes to but
that's actually a spell for the for the
demons but they can use a portal and if
you know the game portal then you know
what portals do it does affect it goes
in one and comes out here exactly yep
yep but if you don't own it you have to
destroy it so that's what the clubby guy
is doing that's actually a club swinger
and yeah every time he had something he
stuns it so and in the back of those
guys you see the little blonde bearded
guys and they throw meat they were aptly
throw name the meat throwers and it's
good it's good very descriptive yeah I
meet eels looks like obviously obviously
and so what is this what is this
delicious meat grill we've opened up
here in the center that's actually the
objective or one of the objectives for
this level is to get some meat on the
BBQ because yeah there is a BBQ so there
should be something that's just the way
God intended yeah exactly so or the way
the games honest in this thing it's kind
of the same thing um so yeah what we're
doing right now is we're trying to get
up dude through the BBQ and get some
meat on there there we go so you
mentioned the portal allowing enemies to
spawn closer or respond to different
locations around the map like why was
that why was that an important feature
you guys wanted to work here um well
insert the soldiers one one of the
problems with this kind of setup it's a
it's a side-scrolling strategy game you
have a base on one end and
the other end and it always our results
in a kind of a target war type situation
and you have to like wait for your
troops to walk on sometimes it comes a
little bit of a waiting game and there's
just one front and we want to want to
introduce a lot of stuff where you can
have multiple fronts in the battles if
they more attention you could do strikes
in the back of your armies base or stuff
like that like back during their workers
and everything like that so there's a
lot of stuff that we do for them so
right now we're actually confronting the
big guy right there that's the demon
super unit yes big shield and a dead
animal on this pack and a dead animal
arms back of course so what we're doing
to take them out is use the Viking super
spell which is old Larry so it is all
about drinking Mead and punching boots
in the phone and uppercutting demons yep
and singing as well so so we took care
of the of the super unit actually when
you control the demon subunit yourself
you'll be able to deploy him and I'll
turn them into a static forum so you
stand still and you start screwing any
allied units that pass him over whatever
is in front of him so you can for units
over powers and so not only like
circumvent defenses that have been set
up but also just get the enemies further
downfield faster it's another thing to
circumvent the stalemates that could
happen in this kind of setup so there's
lettuce like it was a problem in certain
soldiers one are you like it do equally
skilled opponents fought each other it
often resulted in a stalemate and we've
just done a lot of stuff to prevent that
in this version of okay so then our is
that sort of portal technology going to
be available in multiplayer matches oh
yeah yep there will be a skirmish mode
where you can play against each other in
split screen or you can play 11 can play
on the hand health and another complain
the TV with a remote she had a really
all kinds of ways to play against each
other and what we want to do with sort
of soldiers do is instead of having
three set factions like in first version
you can create your own army we can like
mix and match different units rediff
exactly so there will be kind of
probably some kind of draft system or
something where you can completely
create your own army from how you want
to be what can you remind us when the
game might be coming out and on what
platforms so there's no promises yet
when it's done basically yeah when it's
done so probably around the end of 2014
beginning 2015